[Música]
desde el inicio del día decenas de
personas ya estaban en el ron Point
cerca de ameam entre ellos el diputado
del partido Francia y sumisa françois no
es cuestión de desarmarse los activistas
quieren creer en una movilización récord
este jueves Espero que las personas
Despierten Y que cuando salgan a las
calles puedan unirse a nosotros para
decirle a macron que no queremos esa
reforma y tampoco su gobierno
desde la adopción de la ley el lunes con
el artículo 49:3 el movimiento de
protesta se ha endurecido con
manifestaciones espontáneas en varias
ciudades empañadas por la violencia
entre ellas París en los pasillos
comerciales parisinos las estaciones de
bicicleta han desaparecido los
contenedores han sido evacuados varios
comercios permanecerán cerrados no
podemos correr el riesgo por nuestros
clientes 12.000 policías se ha
movilizado 5.000 de ellos en París mil
más que en ocasiones anteriores
se han creado muchos ataques
incendiarios este tipo de abuso es
especialmente temido por los
comerciantes
los sindicatos llaman a la calma y a la
continuación de un movimiento ejemplar
evidentemente hago un llamado a que haya
cero violencia ni para las personas ni
para la infraestructura que no haya ni
violencia física ni violencia simbólica
un movimiento que aún podría continuar
el grupo intersindical se reunirá
después de las manifestaciones de esta
tarde en el que tendrá que decidir otros
días de movilización
[Música]